ja auf wen und auf was kann man sich in
dieser corona-krise eigentlich noch
verlassen das was mal versprochen wurde
das gilt dann wenig später plötzlich
nicht mehr neuestes Beispiel das
betrifft genesene also alle die die
Corona überstanden haben ja und das das
ist echt ein Hammer denn plötzlich seit
dem Wochenende gilt dass man nur noch
drei Monate lang als genesener Geld
statt wie bisher sechs Monate das ist
eine ganz wichtige Änderung hier schauen
sie mal auf der Internetseite des
Robert-Koch-Instituts da hat mal das mal
eben so heimlich still und leise am
Wochenende geändert das nämlich der
genesenen Status nach drei Monaten weg
ist ab jetzt ja das sorgt natürlich für
heftige Aufregung bei uns im Studio ist
jetzt Bild meinungschef Philipp Pia Toff
den wir fragen wollen Philipp schönen
guten Tag wie kommt das eigentlich dass
das Robert Koch-Institut das so ganz
unauffällig und leise ändern kann ja
also das Robert-Koch-Institut ist ja
eine Behörde die zum
Gesundheitsministerium gehört und ist
offenbar zu der Einschätzung gekommen
dass der genesenen Status nach drei
Monaten abläuft weil danach der Schutz
vor einer Infektion vor einem schweren
Verlauf möglicherweise nicht hoch genug
ist ob das Robert-Koch-Institut diese
Entscheidung tatsächlich mit ausreichend
Daten hinterlegt sein hat das bezweifle
ich ehrlich gesagt weil ganz viele
andere Experten auch die Gesellschaft
für Virologie bis beispielsweise bis vor
kurzem noch etwas ganz anderes gesagt
haben die haben gesagt man muss den
genesenen Status von 6 auf 12 Monate
verlängern man muss zumindest genesen
auch geimpften gleichstellen das war
bislang der Konsens den bricht das
Robert-Koch-Institut einfach so mal auf
und beschneidet damit ihr die Rechte von
Millionen Menschen durch diese Passage
da auf der Website das ist schon Dinge
nur wer ganz spitzfindig war wer richtig
nachgeschaut hat am Wochenende auf
dieser Seite der hat das dann gefunden
dann hat das daraufhin eine riesen Welle
gemacht für heftig Aufregung gesorgt
weil viele was anderes versprochen haben
auch Karl Lauterbach selbst der
Gesundheitsminister schauen wir mal rein
was er noch vor Monaten dazu gesagt
man könnte tatsächlich die Antikörper
sehr viel
ja interessanter nutzen als wir das
derzeit tun weil wir wissen dass der
genesenen Status sehr gut schützt am
Anfang sah es zeitweise so aus als wenn
die Impfung besser schützen würde als
der genesenen Status das hat sich als
falsch erwiesen das ist einfach nicht
richtig also wir wissen heute dass der
genesenen Status sehr umfänglich schützt
und wir wissen auch dass der genesenen
Status ganz gut schützt über die sechs
also Monate hinaus von daher könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass wir den genesenen
Status also mit dem Antikörper also
Nachweis so nutzen dass man auch über
die sechs Monate hinaus noch als genesen
gilt
also ganz genau das Gegenteil von dem
was jetzt passiert Philipp piathoff 6
Monate und sogar darüber hinaus das kann
sich der Gesundheitsminister vorstellen
jetzt aber kommt das RKI und sagt nein
drei Monate länger nicht tja also es
scheint mir als hätte Karl Lauterbach
seine Behörde die sein unterbehörde das
Robert-Koch-Institut nicht im Griff weil
erneut erlaubt sich das
Robert-Koch-Institut etwas was von der
Politik so nicht kommuniziert wurde und
ich verstehe überhaupt nicht warum das
Robert-Koch-Institut ehrlich gesagt auch
nach so vielen Versäumnissen in den
alleinlichen vergangenen Monaten nach
den ganzen falschen Prognosen nach dem
datenblindflug über den Jahreswechsel
überhaupt noch so etwas entscheiden darf
wir haben dazu ja ein Expertenrat den
hat Olaf Scholz der Bundeskanzler
berufen da sitzen renommierte Virologen
und andere Experten drin man könnte die
Frage wie lange ein genesener denn
geschützt ist ja auch in die Hände des
expertenrats legen dort hätte man eine
unabhängige Entscheidung mit vielen
Meinungen mit sehr breit gestützt und
jetzt macht das ist das RKI einfach mal
so am verwendet das ist wirklich der
wundert mich nicht dass die Bürger dem
einfach nicht mehr glauben dass auch
nicht verstehen das Institut macht was
es will ganz offenbar so siehst du das
Philipp und auf welcher Basis eigentlich
das hat ja offenbar keine richtige
Experten medizinische Basis ist das eine
politische Entscheidung von dem Institut
mit Blick auch auf eine mögliche
Impfpflicht
mir scheint das auch eher eine
politische Entscheidung zu sein weil
bevor man so eine Entscheidung trifft
müsste man ja eigentlich Studien
durchführen um zu schauen ist das
tatsächlich so dass durch Omikron der
der genesenen Status massiv verkürzt
werden muss weil die Leute
beispielsweise schon drei Monate nach
einer Genesung ein kaum mehr wirksamen
Schutz haben aber unsere Datenlage in
Deutschland reicht dazu gar nicht aus
wir wissen nicht mal wie viele genesene
es gibt andere Länder wie Dänemark wie
Großbritannien haben das sehr
systematisch gemessen um abzuschätzen
wie hoch war eigentlich die Dunkelziffer
der Infizierten um auch zu wissen wie
viele Menschen haben sich denn insgesamt
infiziert also wie hoch ist die
Grundimmunisierung in der Bevölkerung
Deutschland hat sowas ja nie gemacht und
das Legen ja auch in der Verantwortung
des Robert-Koch-Instituts also der
Fehler ging damit los dass wir nicht mal
wissen wie viele genesene wir haben und
wir enthalten deshalb Menschen ihre
Rechte vor und jetzt beschneiden wir sie
noch stärker einfach weil das
Robert-Koch-Institut eine Laune hatte
die es bislang der Öffentlichkeit noch
nicht erklärt hat es war auch alle nicht
wissen philipp ist wann hat diese
Pandemie endlich ein Ende und da gibt es
ordentlich zoffen wir anschauen was die
Virologen sagen denn die widersprechen
sich durchaus wann dieses Ende in Sicht
ist wann wir damit rechnen können da
gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen ja
absoluter zeichnet sich gerade bei
einigen eine interessante Kurs Korrektur
an beispielsweise auch bei Christian
Drosten dem renommierten Virologen dem
Chef Virologen der Charité den wir auch
hier im Hintergrund sehen Christian
Drosten war ja immer einer der ganz
großen Mana in der Pandemie das kann man
richtig oder falsch schwinden aber wenn
man sich seine aktuellen Äußerungen
durchliest dann hört er sich für mich
zumindest immer stärker an wie Hendrik
Strick schauen wir mal drauf auf die
aktuellste Äußerung von Christian
Drosten also den den wir alle immer dem
Team Vorsicht zugeordnet haben
eigentlich Mannschaftskapitän dieses
Team vor sich sehr sagt jetzt wir haben
jetzt schon ein ganzes Stück dieses
Weges geschafft über Impfung den müssen
wir jetzt zu Ende gehen damit wir im
Laufe des Jahres 2022 in die endemische
Phase kommen und den pandemischen
Zustand für be erklären können also das
ist ganz wichtig auch wenn es sehr
wissenschaftlich klingt von der Pandemie
in die enemy bedeutet Ende der Pandemie
das ist ein neuer Zustand wo wir normal
werden wieder ja das hört sich doch
erstmal ganz gut an also wenn mir ein
Virologe jetzt sagt also Ende des Jahres
dann wird es auch wirklich deutlich
lockerer er sagt auch Ende des Jahres
steigen noch mal die Inzidenzen das wird
nicht ganz wie bei einer Grippe aber
vielleicht werden wir Masken tragen
müssen mehr aber auch nicht dann sage
ich gekauft das nehme ich vor allem all
das noch in diesem Jahr also das ist
eine echte Aussicht die Männer
gezeichnet wird
es wäre so schön wenn es vorher käme
aber der Lauterbach sieht es halt anders
der hält dagegen schau mir drauf was der
aktuelle Bundesgesundheitsminister sagt
obwohl jetzt selbst wie gesagt Christian
Drosten sagt da ist ein Ende in sich
sagt er das Varianten Alphabet wird
nicht mit Omicron Enden es gibt keinen
einzigen mir bekannten namhaften
Wissenschaftler der behauptet das omicon
das Ende von Corona ist das sagt
Thorsten ja auch nicht nicht das Ende
von Corona aber am Ende der Pandemie und
er Karl Lauterbach der schlägt da schon
ein eher noch alarmistischen er warnende
Toner wie ich ein ganz anderen Ton wenn
man jetzt sagen wir mal Herrn Lauterbach
das Interview von Christian Drosten im
Tagesspiegel vorlegen würde dann würde
Karl Lauterbach sagen ich stimme diesem
Mann in jedem Punkt zu aber der Ton
macht ja die Musik und der Ton ist ein
ganz anderer und der Ton von Karl
Lauterbach ist bloß keine Entspannung
bloß keine Lockerung und
auf gar keinen Fall darf man jetzt
Anfang an der Impfpflicht zu zweifeln
wir müssen jetzt uns vorbereiten auf
einen ganz langen Zeitraum wir müssen
jetzt impfen um den nächsten Winter die
absolute Hölle zu verhindern das ist das
was aus dem Interview mit Karl
Lauterbach hervorkommt und das ist ein
ganz anderer Toner der Welt am Sonntag
was große Interview von Karl Lauterbach
das heißt er läuft im Grunde der Zeit
hinterher die Politik die Regierung
läuft der Zeit und selbst den
vorsichtigsten Wissenschaftlern wie
Christian Drosten hinterher absolut er
wird ehrlich gesagt immer einsam
zumindest politisch gesehen selbst
Markus Söder der Chef der den anderen zu
Schäfte selbst einen ausgerufenen Teams
Vorsicht selbst der hat ja schon offen
eine Kurskorrektur angekündigt und sagt
wir müssen mehr an die Kollateralschäden
der Maßnahmen denken wir müssen mehr an
wirtschaftliche psychische soziale
Schäden denken und Karl Lauterbach
bleibt dabei ihm geht es vor allem darum
Corona zu bekämpfen die Zahlen so
niedrig es geht zu halten während
Christian Drosten langsam die Abkehr
davon verkündeten auch schon in einem
Podcast gesagt hat man könnte die
Quarantäne ganz abschaffen der jetzt in
diesem Tagesspiegel Interview gesagt hat
no Co wird diese Bewegung mit der man
Inzidenzen niedrig halten wollte mit der
er übrigens durchaus auch sympatisiert
hat das waren die realisierbar das war
also das das hätte nie im Leben geklappt
dass ein gut dass wir das nicht gemacht
haben deswegen da merkt man schon einige
Leute versuchen ihren Kurs zu
korrigieren auch in der Öffentlichkeit
ihren Kurs zu korrigieren während Karl
Lauterbach sich treu bleibt